the following information shows a group
of people's waist measurements and
weight and then you can see the table
below now what we're being asked to do
is calculate a correlation coefficient R
for the waist and weight measurements
and then we'll use that to describe the
strength of the relationships so if you
want to think back we had a single
variable that we had to put in our data
into our calculator but now we've got
bivariate data there's the waist and
then there's the weight and very
helpfully the question has even taught
us which one is X and which one is Y so
again we'll come over to our calculator
now I'm just like before I'm gonna clear
out all of the data that was in there
all right it's all clear and now when I
go to set up stat for two you can see to
get into bivariate data rather than
pressing one for a single variable I'm
gonna press 2 which is a plus BX and I'm
just going to jot that down for a second
a plus B X that's what tells me that
there's going to be two variables there
and I'm gonna return that a plus BX and
we have a look at the next question but
for now let me hit too and as we
hopefully anticipated you've got the two
columns there to put in your waist data
and your weight data so let's go ahead
and put those in now if I press 103
which is the first waist piece of data
and press equals you notice it goes down
to the next value for X so it's not
going to be 82 which is a weight score
it's going to be 88 which is the waist
score so I'm gonna do all of those waist
pieces of data 88 67 I'm gonna do all
these in a row 72 96 eighty one ninety
nine and ninety okay
so there's all of the waist measurements
and I'll just again as I usually do go
back and check that all my numbers are
in the clear great and then I'll go over
to the weights so these are the Y's and
I'm gonna put them all in order as well
82 first if you press equals you can see
again it goes down the list just like it
did before so 73 51 60 to 85
71 81 and lastly 79 and thankfully you
can see all of my ex scores line up with
all of the wives score so at least I
know there's the same number of both I
just double check that all of my scores
in put it correctly I'm happy with that
okay so now I'm gonna clear that all the
data has been saved how do I get to the
correlation coefficient well like before
to get into the menu for this I'm gonna
go shift and then one the menu that I'm
wanting to go into now is five for re G
stands for regression so if I press five
there and the one that I'm after here
the correlation coefficient the question
itself even reminds us that's denoted by
an R maybe it's a reminder because R is
such a weird counterintuitive letter to
choose for correlation coefficient so
I'm gonna go ahead press three there and
it gives me a value so I'm gonna write
from the calculator I'm getting a value
of R equals zero point nine four seven
six six to eight dot dot dot that's what
the correlation coefficient is but now I
need to draw a conclusion off of that so
it says describe the strength of the
relationship now this requires you to
think back to what the different options
are for you know how high can this value
R go I'm gonna actually go all the way
back in the paper to this part here if
you have a look at this closely
correlated data here over on the left
hand side they're closer all of those
data points clinging to the line of best
fit
The Closer your correlation coefficient
gets to one whereas if you have a look
at this data set B over here because
they just scattered everywhere you're
going to have a correlation coefficient
of about zero now I should correct on
data set a because it's a negative
correlation I'm actually going to get
something like negative one but the
point is it's very far away from zero it
ranges from negative one to one so I'm
looking for values like that now if you
have a look down to this question now we
can interpret this 0.94 is that high or
is it low and the answer is it's very
very close to one
so what I would say is this is a strong
and it's positive because it's not
negative zero point nine four seven etc
it's a strong positive correlation so
that's all we needed to comment on that
finding the equation of the least
squares regression line that's what Part
B is asking for now again we've actually
done all the hard work entering that
data into the calculator we just need to
go back to it so let's just get here I'm
going to clear this out now to get to
the equation of the least squares
regression line we need two things we
need a gradient of the line then we need
a y-intercept so when you go to shift
one to bring up these options here I'm
going to go back to five for our eg
again and this is where I'm going to
remind you that when we selected this
statistical mode in the first place we
this mode was called a plus BX now that
a plus BX refers to the equation of the
least squares regression line that a is
going to be the y intercept and the B is
going to be the gradient so let's work
out what those two numbers are each in
turn a is going to be let's have a look
here it's going to be one press equals
there so that gives me negative one
point two three six nine seven nine dot
dot dot and then I'm going to clear that
and I'm gonna do the same thing and now
I'm gonna ask for B so it is two because
that so that's B so that gives me zero
point eight five three two nine eight
six dot dot dot okay
now I take that and I put it into my
equation which I said from the beginning
was a plus B X that's what the
calculator used so I'm just going to put
these in negative one point
- I'm gonna round it off there to two
decimal places and then I'm going to add
zero point eight five and it just rounds
down to five so X to two decimal places
whoops just change the page there by
accident there we go so it was very
common for students to think that B
was actually the y-intercept because if
you think back to when we last first
learned corner geometry we tended to
write straight lines in this form y
equals MX plus B so I know that is a bit
confusing it's because you're coming
from the coordinate geometry world and
the people did the way people did things
in that conventional there was like this
but in the statistical world and the
calculator itself reminds you we write
it in this form so the B is the gradient
and you've got to remember not to switch
those around very common mistake